oui on me voit daniel caron et luc
leblanc nous ont guidés dans la caverne
de saint léonard
c'est ici en octobre qu'ils ont réalisé
leurs grandes découvertes
première étape franchir la galerie déjà
connu langue d'une quarantaine de mètres
est visitable chaque été depuis les
années 80 on avait identifié entre
autres avec la radiesthésie c'est la
technique des sourciers le fait qu'elle
va probablement une galerie au delà de
la grotte taux nul afin d'amener plus en
plus corsé
nous avons sont un peu plus loin là où
en fouillant les deux spéléologues ont
trouvé une couche de calcaire qui
semblait plus facile à briser apparu
alors une fissure puis le vide cet
endroit là c'est la lucarne que nous
avons élargi par ce ton grand quand un
fonds de bouteilles en fait est qu'on a
élargi et qui donne vraiment sur le
flanc sur le plafond de la grande
galerie
donc nous sommes en terrain vierge les
quelques mètres qui suivent son sportif
il faut ramper s'accrocher à une corde
se tenir à l'échelle et voilà la toute
nouvelle galerie longue d'environ 275 m
et haute de six mètres
ces lieux ont été formés lors de la
dernière période de glaciation il y à au
moins quinze mille ans
c'est immense est vraiment
impressionnant et là actuellement je
marche là où avant le mois d'octobre
personne dans l'histoire de l'humanité
n'avait mis les pieds nous ne sommes
pourtant qu'à dix mètres sous le parc
pie xii dans l'arrondissement saint
léonard
la découverte est unique au québec la
période par persévérance à découvrir des
nouvelles par est une installation avec
d'autres repreneurs exceptionnel doté au
plafond des dizaines de stalactites
assez exceptionnel parce que dans les
conditions québécoise
il faut presque mille ans pour que se
crée un petit centimètre de stalactites
puits au fond de la grotte
c'est tout cristalline et un touché qui
provient de la nappe phréatique
montréalaise
nous n'avançons pas plus loin
mais les deux spéléologues l'ont fait et
nous ont fourni des photos par une
escalade nous avons rejoint par le
passage supérieur qui lui nous a amené à
la suite de cette galerie nos convois
que le plan d'eau et qui ne se poursuit
sur plus d'une centaine de mètres en
fait perdre aux profonds par les parois
ils sont encore plus lisse et verticale
et le plafond de rock impeccable dit
daniel caron et on se bouge 12 n'ont
pour l'instant on est arrêté donc à se
convertir une centaine de mètres de
parcours le plafond se rapproche de
l'eau réformer le montant dont une plus
basse au port est un cadeau pour
montréal et l'arrondissement de saint
léonard
nous avons commandé une étude pour
savoir exactement où ces galeries vont
se rendre une fois qu'on aura leur
rapport nous allons présenter ça au
public et par la suite j'ai imaginé y
aura des visites un jour pas si lointain
qui sait le parc pie xii deviendra
peut-être une attraction incontournable
pour les amoureux de la nature et pour
les curieux ici jean-sébastien cloutier
radio canada n'ont rien